[Music]
Cassini's dive into Saturn capped off 20
years of scientific discoveries and
breakthroughs and even though the
deep-space probe is no more its
sacrifice is yielding results during the
orbital maneuvers that brought the probe
closer and closer to the gas giant
Cassini passed inside the Rings and
skimmed the planets upper atmosphere
several times on the first eleven orbits
the probe took measurements using the
radio and plasma wave science instrument
and when scientists looked at the data
they found that Saturn has a cold dense
ionosphere
Cassini's data provides the first
up-close measurement of the gas giants
charged upper atmosphere ionosphere ZAR
created with ultraviolet radiation from
the Sun it's the atoms of a planets
upper atmosphere splitting some of the
atmospheric particles into charged ions
and forming a plasma if you've ever
picked up a radio broadcast from
thousands of miles away you've
interacted with Earth's biosphere which
reflects radio signals around the planet
however Saturn's ionosphere is a little
different than Earth's the planets
enormous rings affect the way that the
ionosphere is charged when Cassini
passed into the shadow of the Rings cast
on the planet the amount of ionized
plasma dropped immensely
Saturn's D ring also appears to be
affecting the ionosphere researchers
theorized that an interaction known as
ring rain may explain some of the
ionosphere squirts while the shifting
plasma in the ionosphere is a major
finding it only came from the first
eleven orbits of data so there's still
much we can learn
Cassini's last hurrah
[Music]